hello everybody my name is fenvinka i
am the director on vault's gate 3. i'm
going to talk you through today
uh all of the cool things that we've
added to bg3
in patch 5. so let's get started
[Music]
one of the highlights for me of patch 5
is the inclusion of what we call the
active roll system
how does it work well it's very simple
whenever there's a check that pops up
you can actually ask your character to
cast a spell to eight fate a little bit
so for instance here
you can see me cast guidance and that's
gonna give me a one to four bonus on the
role that i need to do
but you could also ask one of the other
party members in your vicinity
to cast a spell to aid your luck a
little bit
and like this you can stack them and
that can make a very big difference in
gameplay to give you an example
i was playing the game earlier today and
i was accessing the chapel there's a a
lockpick check that you can do there and
usually that fails because it has a very
high dc number it has a 20
which you need to imagine that's very
high but with the 8
of my cleric shadow heart i managed
actually to
open that door something that i hadn't
managed without cheats in a long time
and so i discovered a completely
different way of entering that chapel
and i was very happy to see also
that our scriptures and the writers had
anticipated all of that and i had a
completely different
entry point to my adventure so be sure
to try out the active role when you
download patch 5
you're going to find that it does quite
a lot of good things
go ah
hello next up is actually a pretty big
feature
which is the background goals when you
create a character in the game
you get to pick a background so you get
to be a full hero for instance or a
novel
well say that you pick fork hero and you
do something that a fork hero would do
in the game then the game is going to
reward you with
an inspiration point or with some
experience if you already
are at your inspiration gap which is
actually also a new thing
but you're gonna find that there's over
a hundred of these goals that were added
in the content of early access
for you to discover and every single
time you're gonna discover one of them
you're gonna see them listed up here in
this neat handy background goal
ui that was added to the game it rises
from the stone
hanging in the air in silent offering
something that you have been asking us
for and something that we actually were
planning for
quite some time is the ability to free
shadow
heart in the tutorial in the past you
couldn't free her but now you can you
don't have to
it's up to you what you do with it but
you can free her and you'll notice that
that introduced a whole bunch of new
permutations to the story
as you'll try out to play the early
access content
you're alive we also added something
that was
also a very big community ask and which
took quite some effort to do because
we're trying to do it right
uh it is what we call the point and
click system
it's very simple whenever you're going
to click somewhere your uh
characters are now going to say
something just like they did in the
original games
so for instance if i ask shadowheart to
walk somewhere she'll say this i must
keep going
but if i ask her to go into sneak mode
she'll save this
unseen as i was taught now the really
cool part about this is that
they will change what they say in
function of where you are in the story
and where you are on their character
arcs depending
on what decisions you make uh for early
access alone we actually recorded for
each of them
over 800 voice bars and we're gonna be
recording much more as we
finish obviously the entire
need to keep focused uh by popular
demand
we split up the uh jump and disengage
this was in the past
uh jumping equal disengage and now we
have a separate disengage action and
jump in
on a thing uh this is popular demand
also from community
uh you can now break concentration
there's a little uh icon there that you
can click on whenever
a character is concentrated if you want
to break their concentration if you're a
pacifist player
you don't necessarily need to kill
everybody anymore you can just toggle
the
non-little attacks if you then start
smacking them you're gonna knock them
unconscious so you can still rob them
blind
you don't have to kill them it's better
for your karma mini camps mini camps
many camps are super cool okay so mini
camps is essentially the feature that
when you go to sleep somewhere the
background setting of your camp
is going to match the place where you go
to sleep remember how in the past when
you go to sleep you were
always in the wilderness always with the
forest background well no more
because if you now go to sleep into the
underdark you're going to be in the
underdark if you go to sleep into the
chapel you're going to be in the chapel
you go to sleep in the cavern guess what
you're going to be in the cavern it's
fantastic it's really adds a lot to the
immersion of your adventure
took a lot of work because we had to
modify all the cinematics to be able to
take place wherever you were
but it was definitely worth it so it
adds a lot uh to the gameplay
you did it you're channeling the weave
speaking of camp again uh there's a
couple of extra cinematics that you'll
find in camp
uh definitely check out uh scratch and
the owlbear if you ever figure out how
you can get and the dog
and the albert cup into your camp it's
possible
then you're gonna have a very adorable
scene as baldur's gate 3
continues to improve its pet simulating
skills
we've added a new feature that we want
to try out during early access and it's
called camp resources
so what it means if you go to sleep now
you're going to be asked what you want
to eat and if you eat sufficient you're
going to have a very
fruitful rest and you're going to
restore all of your spouse laws and
all of your hp if you are for instance a
wizard
however if you don't have enough
supplies you will have what we call a
shallow rest
and you're gonna be able to restore
everything the reason we did it is
because we want to differentiate
stronger between short
rest and long rest and so we're very
curious to see how it's going to play
for you so do
let us know what you think of our camp
supplies system
it definitely adds a lot to finding food
in the world and
uh you will notice that as you continue
playing the game
the cost of uh going to rest is going to
increase
as you level up and that actually
reflects the the growing upkeep of your
ever
increasing camp in the game so very
curious to see what you're gonna do with
that
i will fill your front with arrows
or you turn around and your backside
gets the same treatment
a strange symbol glows marked on their
flesh
and something within you stirs in
response
and there is a lot more now i'm not
going to go through the list of
everything there's just too much but i
do want to share
a story with you of how this patch
changed my own gameplay experience and i
was really happy with what i saw
so i already mentioned to you that using
my active role i actually managed to
open that chapel door something which i
hadn't done in a long time
so i went inside and as i went inside
uh i had some traps to deal with and i
had a little fight that i need to do
and then i went to sleep and as i went
to sleep i had enough supplies so i ate
my supplies
and i was super happy to see that i was
actually standing
inside of the chapel as i went uh to
sleep
rather than being in that wilderness it
just felt right
and then when i walked outside of the
chapel and i
surprised those bandits that are there
something that you usually don't see
because typically you would go
from the other side and just meet the
bandits in their normal default script
setting
they reacted to it i saw a scene that i
hadn't seen in a long time there was a
guy yelling at me
hey somebody's coming out of the crypt
and i was feeling like
hey this is how it should be it's a
small thing but it was important to me
so i wanted to share it with you because
this is uh essentially the incremental
nature of development
things are starting to come together and
as they're starting to come together
we can start seeing the light at the end
of the tunnel of development where the
game eventually is going to be released
so i hope that when you're going to try
patch 5
you're going to have the same conclusion
because it is actually getting
a lot better
you